do you think there's
concrete groups like is it as simple as
the two groups of blue and red
no it's it's it's it's also very fluid
because you and i
are allied as jewish people as russians
as males
as podcasters uh you're an academic i'm
not
there so there's there we're different
but we each are
a venn diagram even within ourselves and
i can talk to you about politics and
then we can talk about russia stuff and
then you could talk about
your your work which i don't know
anything about so that would be what
you're way up here in our way down here
so there's lots every relationship with
just between individuals
there's it's very dynamic so how do we
succeed like how do we form individual
states
sure there's a little bit more cohesion
sure
the the and voluntary cohesion so the
first step is to
uh um eliminate and the concept of
political authority as legitimate
and to denigrate and humiliate those who
would put themselves
in a position in which they are there to
tell you how to
live your life from any semblance of
validity
and that's starting to happen if you
look at what they had with the lockdowns
cuomo and de blasio new york
uh we have i was uh tired a couple weeks
ago
and i said to my friend oh just click
maybe i've covered and he goes it's not
possible like what do you mean
and he goes we haven't had any deaths in
like
two months and there's only like 100
cases a day
for like two months and i go you're
exaggerating because everything was
still closed
and i looked at the numbers and he
wasn't exaggerating and there's no
greater american dream to me
then an immigrant family comes to the
states forms their own little business
maybe mom's a good cook is a restaurant
dry cleaner fruit stand
and those people aren't going to have a
lot of money those are the first ones
who lost their
companies because of these lockdowns uh
they cuomo who's the governor of new
york opened up the gyms he said you're
clear to open up
de blasio said and we don't have enough
inspectors you're gonna have to wait
another couple weeks
uh to regard that as anything other than
literally criminal
is something that i am having a hard and
harder time
wrapping my head around you said i mean
that's something i'm deeply worried
about as well which is
like thousands it's actually millions
of dreams being crushed that amer
american dream of starting a business of
running a business
what about all the young people who you
and i have in our audiences
who are socially isolated at best and
now they can't leave their homes
uh isolation and ostracism are things
that are very well studied in psychology
these have extreme consequences i read a
book called ostracism
and this wasn't scientific but basically
the author was a psychiatrist psychology
whatever
and he had one of his colleagues they
did an experiment let's for a week
you ostracized me completely we know
it's an and he goes
even knowing it's the experiment the
fact that he wouldn't make eye contact
with me and the fact that he ignored me
had an extreme emotional impact on me
knowing full well this is purely for
experimental purposes now you multiply
that by all these p
the suicide the number of kids who think
about suicide was through the roof
during all this uh and my point is until
these people
it's gonna i would predict like 2024
that's where we're going to have to
start having conversations about what
personal consequences
have to be done for these people because
until then they're going to do the same
thing
so you think there's going to be
society-wide consequences of this that
we're going to see like ripple effects
because of the social isolation i i know
i mean we also need to talk about
consequences or cuomo de blasio
because if if politicians respond to
incentives and the incentives are there
for them to be extremely conservative
because if you have to choose as cuomo
center press conference between
a thousand people dying and a thousand
people losing their business it's not a
hard choice and he's right
but at a certain point it's like all
right you're losing
both you're losing not losing the you're
making these decisions
um and not having consequences for it
and you're going to do it again the next
time
so we need to make sure you're a little
scared okay and i don't know what that
would mean
but you're laying this
problem this this incompetence i don't
think it's incompetence i think it's
very competent i think they're just
their jobs malevolence yes but what
but you're laying it not at the hands of
the individuals but the structure of the
of government it's both yes
how would we deal with it better without
centralized control
well we didn't really have centralized
control because every country and every
state you know handled it in a different
mechanism but a city has centralized
control just yeah
right i mean no that's not true so cuomo
de blasio they had a lot of
disagreements over this
over the months and this was actually a
source of great interest and tension
um de blasio wanted at one point was
talking about like quarantining people
in their homes
cuomo was like you're crazy uh something
same thing with the schools same thing
with the gyms
and there are other such examples but
the point being this was an emergency
this is world war one i talked about
some timpool show
um was very dangerous because it gave a
lot of
evil people some very useful information
about what the
country will put up with and what they
can get away with under wartime and this
set the model for
things like the new deal and the other
things of that nature
it is undeniable you're a scientist so
you understand this perfectly well
um that this lockdown gave some very
nefarious people
some very valid data about how much
people will put up with
under uh pressures from the state
you